-Thank you for coming back.
It's so great to see you
in person.
Thank you for playing
"Cold As Ice."
-Oh, thank you for --
Yeah, thank you for having me.
As always, very excited.
-Yeah.
-We've never played
that game before.
-I know. I'm honored.
-I don't know if we'll
ever play again.
-We'll see.
We'll see, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I have to talk to you
about this
because you know I'm the biggest
fan of Weird Al Yankovic.
-Yeah, yeah.
-He's my favorite.
He was my first concert
I ever saw.
-I think that's incredibly cool.
-I love that guy so much.
And you are playing Weird Al
in a biopic movie.
-Yes.
-This is --
-It's awesome.
-I mean, how --
I cannot wait for this.
-It's the thing --
I'm rarely excited
to see the stuff that I'm in.
I'm very, very excited
to see that.
It is -- I mean, you know,
it's a fully insane movie.
It's one of the most fun things
I've ever done.
And yeah, I don't know
when exactly it'll be out --
hopefully later this year --
but, you know,
it's one to look forward to.
-How did it come about?
Have you ever met Weird Al?
-So, apparently --
'Cause when they --
When I talked to Al
for the first time, I was like,
"I'm immensely flattered
by the idea that you would
pick me to play you.
But like, why me?"
You know, I'm mystified,
but excited.
And apparently, so --
like, 13, 14 years ago,
I sang a version
of a Tom Lehrer song
on "The Graham Norton Show"
in the UK.
-Sure.
-I sang "The Elements"
next to Colin Farrell
and a very bemused Rihanna.
I think he was just like,
"Who is this kid,
and why is he singing all of
'The Elements'?"
And I guess Al saw that
and was like,
"This guy maybe gets it."
And so picked me to -- yeah.
So I'm very, very lucky.
-I love that.
-And now I've gotten to --
you know, I got to have,
like, accordion lessons with Al.
So it's --
I can go to my grave --
-I would start crying
thinking about it.
You brought us an awesome photo
of you with Al's accordion.
-Yes. So I got lent
Al's accordion for the month.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-That is --
That was my last day
with the accordion.
I was very sad to be having
to say goodbye to it,
'cause he gave me
his own accordion
to practice on for the month.
On day two of that,
I broke one of the straps.
[ Audience groans ]
So immediately --
Yes, that's how I felt.
[ Laughter ]
And then immediately
got them replaced and he was --
Again, thankfully,
he's, like, the nicest guy.
-Yeah.
-If he was furious about it,
he kept it to himself.
-I cannot wait
to see that movie.
I'm so excited.
I think the casting is perfect.
I love that you said
yes to that.
You obviously have
already been part
of one of the biggest
movie franchises in the world.
And now fans of yours online
want you to play Wolverine.
Have you heard this?
-I have heard this.
This is something
that has, like, come up
every so often
for the last few years.
And every time it comes up,
I'm like, "That's not true.
There's nothing behind that."
And everyone's like,
"Oh, he said it might be true."
And I'm like, "No, I didn't.
I said the opposite of that."
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no.
You said the word "true."
That counts.
-And then, like, every so often,
I'll get bored answering
the question in a sensible way,
so I'll make a joke,
and every time I make a joke,
I'm like, "Why did you do that?
That's gonna set --"
So the other day, I was like,
"Prove me wrong, Marvel."
And then that has ignited
a whole thing.
But yeah, I think it's 'cause
there -- like,
Wolverine in the comics
is fairly short,
so I think it's people
going like,
"Who's a short actor?
Him. He can maybe play him."
-That's why. Yeah.
-Yeah, I think so.
-Well, yeah.
I mean, I think you would be
a fantastic Wolverine.
-That's very kind.
Thank you.
I mean, anything that implies
the fleetingest similarity
to Hugh Jackman
is incredibly flattering.
So I'm happy with that.
-Yeah.
[ Audience cheers ]
I'm so happy you decided
to announce it on our show
that you are playing Wolverine.
This is great.
-No!
No, it's not.
-It's so exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come back -- [ Laughs ]
Come back when
the movie comes out.
-Yeah, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-We had Rupert Grint
on the show last week.
-Cool.
-He's great. Funny.
We're talking -- And we talked
obviously about the reunion.
-Yeah.
-The "Harry Potter" reunion.
Was it 20 years?
-Yeah, it was 20 years
since the first film.
-It's got to be --
It's got to be exciting
or was it odd, is it emotional
when you meet your cast
that you grew up with basically?
-It was all of that.
I mean, it was really --
it was lovely.
It was so nice to see --
some people obviously
you've kept in contact with,
and some people
you haven't as much.
It was lovely to see them again.
People like the Phelps twins
who, you know, when we started,
they were like 14 and I was 11.
And at that age, that's,
like, a massive difference.
-Yeah, they're like 80...
-Right.
-...and you were 3.
That's how it felt at the time.
-"You're 14?! Oh, my God!"
-And then now, it's just, like,
we're all men in our thirties.
Like, it's all so flattened out
in a really nice way.
So it was lovely seeing them.
I was also -- I was reminded --
you know,
I was kind of going back like,
I'm very happy
to have these memories.
It's amazing.
Also happy it's not
my day-to-day anymore.
That is also, like --
it's kind of nice.
-Yeah, you made it through.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And you turned out okay.
-And it's nice to be able
to like, celebrate it.
-Yeah, exactly.
We were talking backstage,
and I said,
do people just yell at you
all the time, like,
"Harry Potter!"
or whatever?
And you said that people
yell, "Elijah Wood."
-I got that one quite recently.
[ Laughter ]
So, there's a long-running thing
with me and Elijah
getting mistaken for each other.
Originally, "Lord of the Rings"
and the first "Potter" film
came out around the same time,
and we are both, you know --
the idea of us is very similar.
We are both, like, short actors
with blue eyes and very pale.
-"The idea of us."
-Yeah, like, we don't actually
look that much alike,
but close enough.
And recently,
a guy just was driving past
on the street in New York,
and I was just standing on
the corner and he just yelled,
"Hey, Elijah! I love your work!"
And I was just like, "Cool!
Thanks, man! Have a good day!"
And in my head,
the thought process was like,
"Well, I don't want to ruin
his day."
Like,
he's had a nice interaction
with Elijah Wood,
as far as he's concerned.
Like, why spoil that?
I don't know if he's a fan
of me, so just give him that.
-You know, we were looking
through old pictures.
We were gonna show pictures of
you and Elijah.
And instead, I found something
that I think is even cooler.
You signed a photo for someone,
an autograph,
and I think this is really
your handwriting,
but you can tell me.
And this is so kind of cute.
-Yeah.
-Is this your signature?
-This is how I signed autographs
from between the ages
of, like, 9 and 10.
-"Magic..."
-"Magic rules OK"
with a lightning-bolt
exclamation mark.
And it was either you got that
or you got "Believe in magic"
or you got "Magic works"
from, like, 2000 to 2008 maybe?
-You don't do it anymore?
-You know, I don't do it.
It's less relevant to, like,
"Equus" and stuff.
Like, it became "This is weird
to write this now."
-Yeah. Yeah.
-But, yeah, that is
my terrible handwriting.
What I'm confused about in this
is why I have apparently signed
a photo of myself with no one
else in it while I am on holiday
on the Sydney Harbor Bridge.
-[ Laughs ]
-I don't know who wanted that,
was like,
"Can I have an autograph?"
"Yes."
"But can I have it of you
in front of the Sydney Opera
House on a bridge?"
-In Australia, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Well, it's
a collector's item now.
-Yeah, apparently.
-'Cause you can't
get this anymore.
I want to talk about
"The Lost City."
-Yeah.
-I'm excited about this movie.
Sandra Bullock,
Channing Tatum --
both awesome people.
-Yes, they really are.
-Did you call Sandra Bullock
"Sandy?"
-It took me so long to get to
that point with her
where I's just be like --
-I'm not there.
-I'm not -- I didn't feel like
I was there even after months
and she was like,
"Really, call me Sandy.
You don't have to call me
Sandra."
And then I would say
in conversation with my friends,
I'd be telling a story
about work,
and I'd be like,
"And then Sandy said --"
And they're like, "Oh, Sandy."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, Mr. Big shot.
-Right.
It's what she prefers!
I hate informality, as well!
[ Laughter ]
-I would even call her
Sandra Bullock.
-I mean, yeah.
-I would say her full name.
-It's definitely hard
to, like --
Growing up on "Potter,"
I obviously worked
with a lot of amazing actors.
But I wasn't necessarily
familiar
with the filmography of
Maggie Smith or Richard Harris
in the way that I grew up
watching...Sandy's films.
[ Laughter ]
And it was incredibly surreal.
-That's how you say
her name now?
Saaandy?
-"Saaandy."
-"Hi, Channing.
Hello, Saaandy."
[ Laughter ]
But yeah.
-Yeah, no.
-One of the nicest human beings.
-And yeah, she's truly amazing.
-How do we set up the film?
-So, it is kind of old fashioned
adventure, rom-com movie.
Sandra and Channing
play love interests.
She is a romance novelist.
Channing is her cover model.
I am a crazy billionaire
who decides to kidnap Sandra
because I think she has the key
to finding some treasure.
And it's a great, fun movie.
I feel like
I've done it no justice.
-No, that's exactly right.
Perfectly done.
Perfectly said.
It's a great popcorn movie.
I love it.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Daniel Radcliffe
and Sandra Bullock
in "The Lost City."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-Hello.
-Where am I?
-Um, you're on my plane.
It's nice, isn't it?
The seats are made
of mama llama leather.
-Well,
I'm getting off your plane.
Unchain me.
-That's your seat belt.
-Did you chloroform me?
People actually do that?
Oh.
Oh!
-Oh.
Well, you know,
it's a classic for a reason.
-My body feels drunk.
-It will wear off in a bit.
-Come on.
That's how you do it.
Daniel Radcliffe, everybody.
"The Lost City" is in select
theaters tomorrow
and everywhere March 25th.